[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec cyril
martinez référent national au numérique
chez les patriots en direct avec nous
bonsoir céline martinez sur ce plateau
maxime thibeault docteur en droit public
bonsoir estime thibault et alexis à
poulain que l'on connaît bien ici
puisque c'est notre aide et deux
oreilles pardon j'en perds mes mots et
vitoria liberté bonsoir alexis merci
d'être avec nous vous avez failli ne pas
être là avec les bouchons c'est pas rien
voilà c'est pas comme km 5 1 on est on
est ravi que vous soyez arriver à temps
alors direction fréjus 1 pour commencer
où marine le pen a transmis les rênes du
parti ce week-end à jordan bardella elle
est devenue très officiellement la
candidate du rassemblement national à la
présidentielle 2022 écouter
en 2022 cette élection présidentielle ne
sera pas seulement un choix de société
comme en plus d'être les précédents
scrutins ce sera un choix de
civilisation
un choix de vie et d'avenir pour nos
enfants un choix de sécurité et de
puissance pour notre pays un soin de
liberté et d'indépendance
en avril 2002 ce sera davantage qu'un
vote
un choix historique
alors au moins c'est clair vous pensez
maxime qui boxait également ce que dit
marine le pen un choix ou historiques
2022 je pense que les années passant il
faut faire un moment le choix de la
france ou bien de la région france au
sein de l'union européenne aux siens au
sein d'un système mondialisé qui
malheureusement fait que notre pays avec
son indépendance et sa souveraineté
disparaît progressivement alors vous
allez marine le pen qui soutient le fait
la france de redevenir une nation vous
avez arnaud montebourg vous avez florian
philippot vous monsieur dupont-aignan
donc vous avez quand même du monde mais
c'est sûr que cette élection de 2022 va
être primordiale pour déterminer de
l'avenir du pays et il est plus qu
urgent d'avoir une solution plutôt
nationale à mon sens qu'une solution
européenne et mondiale on voit derrière
toutes les conséquences au plan
industriel son plan économique pour le
pays
même diagnostic avec six poulains 2022
ça sera un choix historique à un
tournant dans les présidentielles ça
dépend vraiment des programmes et des
candidats parce que comme on a cinquante
nuances de vert chez les écologistes on
a un peu 50 nuance de souverainisme chez
les candidats déclarés souverainiste en
réalité il faut les moyens de cette
souveraineté retrouvée je ne sais pas si
on les a si l'on peut les avoir en cinq
ans ça me paraît court et puis tous ont
toujours un rapport assez ambiguë avec
l'union européenne personne ne parle
réellement de frais xi tenir dans le dcu
c'était le cas de marine le pen à
l'élection précédente elle a totalement
changé aujourd'hui il est question de
revoir un peu les traités de penser que
le droit français c'est supérieur au
droit européen et le traité c'est loin
d'être le cas donc cette question là oui
évidemment elle va être importante pour
l'échéance 2022 mais attention encore
une fois il ya beaucoup de nuances et
beaucoup de promesses c'est une élection
présidentielle la réalité d'une
souveraineté retrouvée pour la france
c'est encore autre chose céline martinez
vu le succès relais des manifestations
organisées ce week-end par notamment les
patriotes 1 le parti de florian
philippot est ce que marine le pen
pourrait renouer justement avec son
ancien comparse où vous ferez vraiment
cavalier seul dans cette élection alors
vous me posez une question qui est assez
vaste je ne peux pas parler au nom de
florian philippot mais à ma connaissance
son souhait est la meilleure stratégie
pour votre parti alors je vous la pose
différemment nous c'est de rester clair
droit dans nos idées marine le pen enfin
vraiment j'ai l'impression d'entendre le
disque rayé
depuis plusieurs années elle parle de
choix historique de liberté et c'est
tout en rognant tout ce qui à tout ce
qui relève de justement de la liberté
l'union européenne les questions de
l'otan
enfin voilà il ya quelque chose qui
tourne pas rond il ya une incohérence
totale avec marine le pen est donc enfin
je pense que les patriotes eux n'ont
rien à faire avec un mouvement qui à
renier tout ce qui faisait sa
souveraineté tout ce qu'ils défendent
est en réalité les questions de
souveraineté française voilà et puis
alexis poule alizés ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de réel candidat qui se prononcent
pour le président si florian philippot
françois asselineau sont deux candidats
clair à dire en vue l'offre existe voilà
juste pour corriger la
alors l'autre fabien qui a lancé sa
candidature ce week-end on l'a dit en
introduction c'était évidemment anne
hidalgo la maire de paris qui s'est
délocalisé pour l'occasion s'est lancé
dans la course 2 à l'elysée depuis le
bord de seine à rouen et côté
aujourd'hui je suis prête
j'ai décidé d'être candidate à la
présidence de la république
cher française et chers français je veux
que tous les enfants de france aient la
même chance que celle qui m'a été donnée
je suis candidate pour offrir un avenir
à nos enfants à tous nos enfants
je veux avec vous tout faire pour
réparer pour retrouver le goût du
dialogue et du débat pour bâtir une
france plus juste plus forte une france
plus sûre dont la voix singulière doit à
nouveau porté en europe et dans le monde
jean-maxime thiébaut changer d'avis
qu'il ya moins d'un an et le prométhée
anne hidalgo de ne pas y aller qu'elle
ne ferait pas campagne
que pensez vous de cette candidature
elle a l'air plutôt de de faire certains
émules en tout cas à gauche à son crédit
on dirait qu'il n'y a que les imbéciles
qui ne changent pas d'avis moi ce qui
m'étonne un petit peu c'est qu'il reste
beaucoup de choses à faire à paris et en
tout cas il ya des conseillers de paris
notamment écologistes ont dit qu on
attendait sa présence moi je me promène
dans paris un alexis poulain eu du mal à
venir
on voit l'état de notre ville qui est
quand même assez catastrophique je
trouve sur le plan parfois même de la
salubrité publique et j'aurais préféré
que madame hidalgo se concentre sur
paris plutôt que d'avoir une candidature
présidentielle dont je ne comprends pas
les ressorts parce qu'en fait elle nous
sort des bons sentiments en permanence à
nous sort des éléments de langage
préparé mais dans le fond tel est son
programme on ne le connaît pas alors
certes l'élection présidentielle c'est
la relation d'un homme ou d'une femme
avec le peuple français mais je ne suis
pas certain que madame hidalgo
correspondent totalement attentes des
français alexis voilà on ne capte pas
des parisiens à ce jour en tout cas
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'eau de
colère chez les ch et les parisiens
aujourd'hui ce voilà ce qu'en dit oui le
bilan
demers est compliqué alors il ya bien
sûr en ligne de mire les jeux olympiques
etc et plein plein de grands projets
comme ça le fait qu'elle soit revenu sur
sa parole bon c'est pas inédit en
politique ça s'est déjà vu après
ces gens là vivent dans un monde qui
n'est pas notre d'une certaine façon
même si on est des commentateurs de ce
monde là mais on voit bien d'ailleurs
elle a pris pour créer son équipe
rapprochée des anciens proches de manuel
valls lors de la primaire du ps donc
c'est un monde qui est en train de
s'écrouler les grands partis qui ont
bien du mal elle elle est candidate sans
programme évidemment elle arrive avec
cette idée de dire bon bah je vais être
une femme donc ça va être quelque chose
de bien et je suis progressiste un peu
comme emmanuel macron mais je suis quand
même du parti socialiste même si on peut
pas penser que manuel valls est encore
de gauche on l'a vu lors de ses
dernières déclarations il soutenait
valérie pécresse aux élections
régionales donc c'est dire le le fossé
évidemment entre les électeurs et ceux
qui aujourd'hui se présente pour pour ce
scrutin et pas de programme c'est
finalement ça choque personne je crois
qu'elle précédent emmanuel macron qui a
dit moi j'ai pas le programme j'ai un
projet donc de toutes façons on verra
bien et cette année on voit très bien
que ce soit mon bout à lindahl go il
arrive parce qu'ils je sais pas pour qui
voter j'ai pas de programme mais on va
faire un truc bricolé un truc dans les
mois qui viennent et puis après on verra
si ça passe c'est un peu plus sérieux
que ça quand même dans une élection
présidentielle si je perdais falloir
réconcilier aussi les différentes
gauches en tout cas arrivent à les
rassembler parce que madame hidalgo les
régionales de l'année dernière elle a eu
du mal avec d'une part une gauche
indigéniste racialiste était soutenue
notamment par madame pulvar elle a eu du
mal à la réconcilier avec la gauche
républicaine et même madame delga qui
soutient aujourd'hui madame hidalgo dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle
s'était indigné du comportement de
madame pulvar quant à accepter les
réunions non mixtes etc donc je pense
que madame hidalgo va passer une
campagne désastreuse où elle va devoir
s'expliquer sur tous les sujets essayer
de réconcilier des gauches différentes
et que finalement elle va perdre
davantage
avoir choisi finalement resté à paris
céline martinez clairement c'est tout ce
que vous avez envie de combattre et les
patriotes anne hidalgo
alors non nous ce qu'on a envie de
combattre c'est bien évidemment l'union
européenne et tout ce qu'ils savent de
plus en plus nos libertés je
souhaiterais juste rajouter quelques je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui a
pu être dit par maxime et par monsieur
poulin mais c'est aussi le signe
vraiment d'une défaillance d'une
désacralisation du 2 de la place
présidentielle du prestige
présidentielle on a eu tellement de
mauvais président une mauvaise image
présidentielle depuis plusieurs
quinquennat que maintenant aujourd'hui
n'importe qui a l'impression qui peut
devenir président demain parce que ça a
été tellement rabaissé la fonction a
tellement été rabaissé qu'on voit des
candidats qui ya 20 ans mais on s'en
serait le poil et madame hidalgo qui se
présente à la présidentielle excusez moi
mais enfin franchement ça montre
vraiment quel niveau on atteint en
france il serait temps vraiment de de se
ressaisir de ce point de vue là alors
oui quand même la chance d'avoir 500
parrainages a rassemblé donc ça va
permettre de faire le criaq il ya quand
même bien filtre lac et qui est
difficile à pouvoir permettre mais en
tout cas pour les candidats de droite si
vous aviez déshabiller bertrand michel
barnier madame pécresse et c est un
moment ils vont être obligés de se
diviser les parrainages et on est sûr
que sur le sur la ligne de départ y aura
beaucoup moins de candidats car dès
aujourd'hui on n'en parle pas beaucoup
en tout cas concernant voilà les
bisbilles à droite les parrainages ça
peut ir finalement jouer les arbitres
selon vous je pense qu'il ya énormément
de mer et de 36000 communes un peu moins
maintenant mais il ya beaucoup d'élus
qui vont attendre de la crédibilité et
je pense que des candidatures sur des
convictions vous rassembler plus
facilement des parrainages que des
candidatures comme ça de communication
c'est pour ça que michel barnier à une
candidature un peu plus souverainiste
alors qu'ils essaient de revenir un peu
sur des termes différents qui travaille
beaucoup les élus locaux parce qu'il
sait qu'il va avoir besoin de ces gens
là anne hidalgo aussi c'est pour ça
qu'elle fait une candidature basée sur
les mers arnaud montebourg pour le
moment a beaucoup plus de mal à
développer cela donc je pense que la
campagne de parrainage commence
aujourd'hui elle va se terminer à peu
près au mois de mars je pense quand on
aura les circulaires officielle du
conseil constitutionnel et c'est à ce
moment là qu'on saura réellement qui
seront les candidats en lice alors autre
information à retenir un seul indice et
eric zemmour inquiet privé de micro en
tout cas d'émission ces news les cartes
de l'antenne suite à la décision du csa
de vouloir compter les interventions de
l'animateur comme du temps de parole
pour le candidat qui n'est pas encore
officiellement écoutez sa réaction ce
matin
je pense que c'est inévitable je pense
que le csa l'a fait exprès après mûre
réflexion pendant le week-end on a bien
compris que c'était la seule solution
raisonnable quand on ne peut pas
résister il faut rompre et résiste et
ailleurs
qui rajoute on veut me faire perdre
non parce que l'état question c'est est
ce qu'il va faire un tour de france de
promo de son livre où est ce qu'il va
être candidat aujourd'hui il n'a pas
donné réponse à cette question mais là
visiblement oui alors après il est pas
privé micro parce qu'il est invité à peu
près partout
mais évidemment sur son émission sur ces
news et des suspendu d'antenne sur ces
12 suite à la décision du csa qui pose
une question importante parce que c'est
un précédent quand même qu'un
éditorialiste soit débranché de cette
façon là en période présidentielle alors
même qu'il n'est pas encore déclaré
candidat ce serait différent s'il était
déclaré candidat
donc là il ya évidemment quelque chose
de l'ordre de la question de
l'organisation du débat public on voit
bien la fébrilité de la majorité avec la
volonté aussi de contrôler et censurer
les réseaux sociaux d'une certaine façon
ensuite le sait ça maintenant la loi sur
l'ingérence étrangère lors des élections
présidentielles qui est en train d'être
discutées au niveau français et au
niveau européen on sent bien qu'il ya
vraiment une volonté de d'encadrer
d'assurer un débat d'une certaine façon
donc je comprends tout à fait les
critiques d'eric zemmour par rapport à
cette décision du csa maintenant il
prétend qu'il dise si oui ou non il va
être candidat mais il veut prendre son
temps évidemment et là maintenant il va
faire son tour de france pour vendre son
livre justement et on va le voir partout
où il va être certainement invités sur
les plateaux pour présenter son livre ça
pourrait en faire un candidat
antisystème idéal maxime thiébaut et
finalement d'une certaine manière le
victimiser le coupé deux de ses élites
justement est peut-être pu donner un
coup de pouce je pense que c'est un fin
stratège et il sait très bien qu'il
devient le candidat système parce qu'ils
avaient des moyens de contrer la
décision du csa juridiquement il était
quand même très peu fondées ils
pouvaient saisir conseil d'état en
référé et je pense que le conseil d'état
aurait été très embêté de ne pas lui
donner raison et pourtant il n'a pas
voulu faire ça recchi s'est mis d'un
commun accord avec ses news à se dire je
vais partir en sorte de grand résistant
contre la meute macro nist alors ça me
fait un peu doucement sourire on verra
comment sa campagne va se décliner parce
que maintenant il est candidat
officiellement but il annonce qu on veut
le faire perdre je ne vois pas comment
il ne peut pas être considéré comme
candidat ce qui est certain c'est
qu'eric zemmour qui au début il faisait
sourire aujourd'hui devient quelqu'un de
crédible dans cette campagne
présidentielle il a un seuil à 8% et il
a un démarrage qui peut être intéressant
pour lui et surtout un pouvoir de
nuisance pour certains partis nôtre
rassemblement national c'est peut-être
aussi de cas chez vous s'il martinez et
les patriotes il ya des idées qui se
rapproche de celle de florian philippot
vous la voyez comment vous cette
candidature n'oublie pas son nom d'
d'eric zemmour alors si tenté qu'eric
zemmour soit candidat moi je ne peux que
m'en réjouir parce que ça va participer
peut-être davantage aux débats alors
désolé jeu de golf viser l'europe l'euro
plan donc je vais revenir là dessus mais
bon beaucoup de choses des banques de
l'union européenne et je pense que si
plus on aura de candidats qui importe un
débat ne serait ce une question sur les
neuf souveraineté sur les lois les lois
supra supranationale que sont les lois
européennes faire prendre conscience aux
français qui a effectivement un problème
actuellement avec notre système tel
qu'il est organisé aujourd'hui est telle
qu'on dépendent de plus en plus dont on
dépend de plus en plus moi je me réjouis
plus on aura de candidats souverainistes
mieux ce sera après est ce que zemmour
est souverainiste ça c'est à notre sa
note des bas mais il pose quand même des
questions intéressantes à ce sujet donc
moi je vais effectivement je les
encourage toute façon dans démocratie
comme l'a dit maxime tout à l'heure les
500 parrainages permettront de décret
n'est certain profil peut-être moins
moins talentueux mais
effectivement si on peut apporter un
débat intéressant on va pouvoir enfin
parler de souveraineté arrêter de parler
on va faire si on va faire ça mais sans
parler une seule fois deux de ces lois
supranationale dont on dépend
il n'y a rien qui change alors que là
effectivement les le fait d'avoir des
candidatures souverainiste enfin dès qu
on a diet des candidatures souverainiste
l'on peut que s'en réjouir donc moi
j'encourage la candidature de zemmour et
de n'importe qui d'autre qui peut porter
ce débat là et faire questionner les
français justement voilà elle est là on
parlait de ce pouvoir de nuisance eric
zemmour c'est celui qui peut faire
perdre en tout cas la droite dure je
sais pas s'il peut faire perdre la
droite dure ce qui peut se passer ce qui
va se passer parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
y à il ya une volonté de recomposition
du paysage politique c'est une
refondation de la droite
puisque la ligne rouge qui avaient été
tracées par jacques chirac a entre
l'extrême droite et la droite
jamais vous n'irez aura sanctionné ll a
commencé déjà être un peu floue et puis
là les coûts totalement en train de
bouger et ça pourrait être
cette candidature qui va vraiment bouger
les lignes on va voir des des
ralliements déjà ce soit marine le pen
ou eric zemmour enfin peu importe mais à
droite on se pose beaucoup de questions
regardez la déclaration d'eric ciotti
lors du rassemblement des républicains
qui a dix mois au deuxième tour je
voterai et moore face à macro mais je
voudrais pas forcément le pen donc le
mouvement est déjà enclenché d'une
certaine façon un peu comme on a vu le
tea party aux états unis qui a emmené le
parti républicain qui a donné à trump
les moyens de gagner en 2016 donc je dis
pas que zemmour a les moyens de gagner
mais il a les moyens évidemment
d'accélérer une refondation de la droite
en france si je clique mère puis il met
sur une ligne quand même qui est très à
droite aussi un sa déclaration sur les
prénoms d'origine française c'est je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il aille aussi à
droite parce que moi même je vous posais
revenir sur ceux sur cette loi là là
parce que pour le coup on a quand même
des militaires français qui avaient des
noms d'origine maghrébine qui sont morts
pour la france donc je ne sais pas le
prénom qu'il fait l'assimilation je ne
le crois plus je pense que c'est plutôt
un comportement c'est autre chose et
j'aurais préféré attendre entendre eric
zemmour ce moment là mais bon ça c'est
un détail en tout cas oui eric zemmour
va être un trouble fait ça c'est certain
qui de ti et il l'allié de qui est il
l'ennemi pour le moment je pense qu'on
n'a pas la réponse
certainement série le mcs martinez we
will très rapidement en fait zemmour
assume clairement faire une ligne trump
heist en france il suffit de voir la
couverture de son nouveau livre c'est un
copier coller de la fiche de donald
trump lorsqu'il faisait mais qu'
american let's get donc il ya une un
copier/coller chez mg en une inspiration
tout un portemanteau en piste chez lui
et les pense que le la logique truck bus
va l'emporter en france et là j'ai un
peu plus de doute parce que la france
malheureusement c'est pas les états unis
et je crois d'ailleurs qu'il a reconnue
ce aspirait s'être inspiré de la fiche
de trump pour la couverture de son livre
l ex époux la route petite information
que j'aimerais vous faire commenté un cd
or mais officiel n'y aura pas de
candidature d'edouard philippe qui
décidément est loyal emmanuel macron oui
alors il a monté un micro-parti
néanmoins donc peut-être qu'il voir
philippe joue les législatives où
quelque chose mais ouais enfin où vous
de oui celle d'après de toute façon
depuis qu'il est au havre il est assez
protégé de tout mais peut-être que la
mise en examen d'un esprit sain dans la
cour de justice de la république lui a
rappelé que lui aussi avait été
perquisitionné et que lui aussi pourrait
se retrouver dans une situation délicate
donc une annonce aussi pour rassurer
l'exécutif et dire non je vivais parce
qu'aussi
merci en tout cas tous les trois c'est
une martinez alexis poulin maxim talbot
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage passionnant merci à vous